venir sur la tentative de cambriolage de
Nicos Aliagas les loups vous allez pas
me cambrioler les
loup ok bon l'annonce a commencé l'année
a commencé brutalement pour l'animateur
qui a été tentative de cambriolage dans
la nuit du 1er au 2 janvier dernier
heureusement Nico ça va bien on est
rassuré voilà il va bien mardi 5
individus hachés de 19 à 23 ans ont été
condamné par le tribunal correctionnel
du valde mararne pour tentative de
cambriolage et association de
malfaiteurs en vue de commettre un
potentiel homejcking Gill verd vous avez
toutes les informations bien entendu et
on a l'avocat de Nico salagas
l'excellentissime Roland Pérez petit
recéap il est avec nous juste
après ces derniers temps la liste des
personnalités cambriolées ne cesse de
s'allonger le fléo du moment les
cambriolages chez les stars et dans la
nuit du premier janvier dernier c'est
autour d'un célèbre animateur télé
d'avoir été visé CIN hommes ont été
interpellés après avoir tenté de
cambrioler la maison de l'animateur
vedette de TF1 Nicos mais la tentative
d'intrusion chez Nicos Aliagas a tourné
court et s'est soldé par
l'interpellation et la condam ation de C
jeunes individus équipés de matériel
suspect
oh il s
éclatéy alors comment comptait-il
procéder recrutement des cambrioleurs
méthode condamnation l'avocat de Nico
alaga sort du silence après la tentative
de cambriolage chez l'animateur ce soir
dans
TPMP regardez qu'il est beau qu'il est
chic qu'il est Roland prez qu'il est
avocat qu'il est maître on l'adore
maître Roland prez merci d'être là c'est
un honneur merci est-ce qu'il y a un
lien entre la tentative de cambrillage
de et celle des autres célébrités ou pas
du tout alors le le mode de
fonctionnement à mon avis oui
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui il y a une
personne qui envoie ces différents
délinquants ces différentes personnes
qui ont été mises en cause et condamnées
alors c'est c'est jamais les mêmes
évidemment mais il y a ce qu'on appelle
une personne qui dirige un peu tout cela
et qui envoie ces gens via des
messageries qui sont des messageries
cryptés des messageries
privé c'estes télégram c'estes signal
par exemple et ces messageries font que
ça se rencontre des gens qui ne se
connaissent absolument pas et qui vont
faire un coup pour se faire un peu
d'argent entre 2500 et 5000 € c'est ce
qui est ressorti de l'audience en tout
cas l'audience il y a quelques jours où
ils ont été finalement arrêtés et
condamnés et il semblerait que ce soit
le le même mode opératoire qui se soit
qui se qui s'est déroulé pour les autres
également soit cambriolage soit
tentative de cambriolage oui g oui il y
aurait entre 5 et 10 équipes avec un ou
deux commanditaires et le procès a mis
ça en lumière c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement il recrute des gens de
profil très différents il y avait par
exemple quelqu'un qui travaille dans la
sécurité qui était criblé de dette il
est recruté pour aller faire un coup au
début on lui dit pas où tu vas
exactement ce sera quelqu'un de célèbre
il y aura un butin intéressant l'alarme
se déclenchera pas donc c'est très
préparé et puis là ça a raté parce
qu'ils étaient vraiment mauvais et puis
par coup de chance ça a raté mais sinon
on a l'impression quand même d'un modus
opérandi qui se répète de célébrité en
célébrité et il y aurait derrière tout
ça un ou deux commanditaires il y en a
un qui étaé mis en cause dans l'affaire
de Monsieur Guillaum par exemple dans
l'affaire d'ussi du boxeur de MMA Cyril
gade mais il a été mis h de cause pour
celle-là voilà exactement il a même été
indiqué que l'un des commanditaires
aurait pu être en prison actuellement et
qu'il aurait pu agir de prison avec
cette messagerie avec son téléphone et
ces messageries soit télégrap encore une
fois signal alors est-ce qu'ils vont ils
ont été condamnés oui ils ont été
condamné assez lourdement il faut bien
le dire parce qu'on est sur une
tentative de cambriolage qui a très vite
échoué puisqu'ils ont essayé de passer
par le portail il pensait que l'alarme
ne fonctionnait pas et heureusement
l'alarme fonctionnait et à partir de là
ben celui qui était rentré pour ouvrir à
ses autres comparse le portail a très
vite compris avec l'alarme qui était
stridante c'est est revenu dans la rue
pour rejoindre la voiture et c'est comme
ça qu'ils ont été très vite arrêtés
puisqu'il y avait une patrouille qui
circulait dans la dans la région où vit
où est installée la maison de de Nico
siagas et donc ils ont été condamnés euh
il y en a deux qui qui ont été condamnés
à 3 ans de prison dont euh 18 mois ferme
pour l'un 2 ans un an ferme pour l'autre
et puis ensuite les trois autres ont été
condamnés à 2 ans de prison dont un an
avec surc ce qui fait que pour les trois
derniers a priori ils vont porter
lorsqu'ils le pourront lorsque sera mis
en en en en moyen le le le bracelet
électronique ils vont pouvoir leur
installer un bracelet électronique ou
oui j'ai une question maîre 4 jours
avant les les bureaux de NCOs les
bureaux parisiens de NCOs avait été
l'objet d'une tentative de cambrillage
porte fracturé est-ce que c'est la même
bande qui aurait non on n pas on a
établi aucun lien c'était deux plaintes
différentes et on a établi absolument
aucun lien entre ce cette tentative de
cambriolage d'un bureau pas grandchose
d'ailleurs et et ce qui est arrivé là
qui était qui aurait été beaucoup plus
grave parce que ça faitord croit dans le
dos ni Nicos il va bien il il est un peu
traumatisé ou pas du tout ça va Nicos
oui alors traumatisé oui je peux dire
qu'il est quand même il est traumatisé
parce que quand quand on trouve dans la
voiture du serflex c'est des colliers de
serrage pour vous ligoter les mains pour
vous ligoter les pieds quand on trouve
du ruban adhésif
pour scotcher évidemment la bouche quand
vous savez que vous êtes avec vos
enfants vous vivez avec votre épouse ce
qui est arrivé chez Monsieur Guillon
d'ailleurs chez l'autre animateur oui
rétrospect tivement vous avez un
préjudice d'anxiété extrêmement
important parce qu'il aurait pu être là
dans sa maison avec ses enfants alors
lors de l'audience les les prévenus ont
quand même dit que les instructions
qu'ils avaient reçu c'était uniquement
de voler assez rapidement de partir très
vite et qu'il n'y ait aucun fait de
violence qu'il soit qui soit commis mais
bon quand on quand on se retrouve avec
une voiture remplie de de serflex et de
et de ruban adhésif alors le le
l'aggravation de la séquestration n'a
pas été retenue par
par peut penser qu'il pourit y avoir une
tentative de séquestration non ça n'a
pas été retenu donc on été retenu
vraiment que tout ce qui qui pouvait
être visible matériellement c'est cette
tentative de cambriolage en bande
organisé oui oui maître on se réjouit de
ses peines pour une fois c'est pas
complètement nul mais est-ce que vous
avez pas peur qu'aujourd'hui le les
citoyens lambda qui regardent ça se
disent bah finalement quand il y a une
sorte de justice à deux vitesses et
quand c'est des personnalités c'est un
tout petit peu plus exemplaire et un
tout petit peu plus fort même si vous
êtes un très bon avocat et c'est
peut-être aussi gr à vous mais voilà que
que par exemple quand c'est un Français
moyen où on a vu par exemple la
grand-mère et sa fille avec le mec qui a
qui a pris presque trois fois rien et
moins que sachez que le tribunal alors
ça l'audience a été a duré 8h donc le
tribunal a fait un travail extrêmement
sérieux les avocats des prévenus ont
extrêmement bien plaidé simplement pour
la plupart à part un ils avaient des
casiers judiciaires longs comme le bras
donc qui ne sont pas leur première à
leur première tentative ou à leur
premièr mé fait hélas la plupart sont
quand même dans des situations il faut
bien le dire il faut bien le reconnaître
dans des situations compliquées
difficiles ces prévus sont venus parler
de leur
situation un était crib d vous l'avez
rappelé Gill d'autres voilà d'autres
sont quasiment sans famille notautre a
une é charge de famille aussi donc voilà
pardon non rien merci vous avez dit
qu'il était
fa excuse non je dis pas
que ce que je veux dire c'est que la
situation elle se réveille au mauvais
moment non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est qu'ils ont pris la
mesure quand même malgré leur situation
ils ont pris la la mesure de de ce qui a
été commis de leur situation et du fait
que ils n'en sont pas à leur premier
coup donc c'est pour ça que les
décisions la décision qui a été rendue n
pas la décision qui a été rendue n'est
pas liée du tout à la personnalité de la
victime Nic d'ailleurs n'était pas là ne
s'est absolument pas exprimé donc elle
n'est absolument pas lié à la
personnalité de la victime elle est liée
au fait je vous dis a quand même il y
avait avant il y avait la séquestration
qui avait été éventuellement prévu puis
a une il y a il y a ce ce ce le fait que
que c'était commis en bande
organisée ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que les commoditaires c'est ceux dont le
seul boulot c'est de loger les
personnalités qui sont potentiellement
des richesses chez eux on trouvé les
stars et CER expqu ce qui est logé parce
qu'on n pas tous des log de de de
trouver le domicile où habite la la
personne la star en question voilà leur
seul boulot c'est de chercher l'endroit
de le domicile et après de de
d'embouucher les hommes de main mais
risqu Ren parce que donc ça va continuer
parce quex ils sont toujours dans
l'ombre protégés par les par les
réseaux on l'a vu pendant l'audience le
le commanditaire il y en avait un qui
avait été désigné au départ il y a eu
une première audience qui était la
l'audience vous savez des des flagrants
d'lit la comparitionition immédiate et
puis ils ont demandé à juste titre de
pouvoir organiser leur défense donc
l'affaire a été renvoyée il y a
quasiment un mois donc tous étaient en
prison pendant ce délai et au départ
lorsqu'on les avait entendu dans la
première fois chacun avait désigné un
des un des CIN qui était un
commommanditaire ouais et puis
curieusement quand l'affaire est revenue
tout le monde a dit ah non non c'est pas
lui c'est pas lui c'est pas lui euh donc
on ne saura pas quel est ce
commanditaire le fait est que ce qui est
certain c'est que les cinq ne se
connaissaient pas il se donnent
rendez-vous à un point c'était euh euh
je sais plus quel était quel était le
point de rendez-vous il se donne
rendez-vous un point la voiture on une
voiture vient les prendre un chauffeur
les emmène ils ne savent pas où ils vont
aller ils ne savaient absolument pas que
c'était la maison de l'animateur donc
ils viennent faire vraiment un un et la
veille seulement ils ont reçu un message
c'est pour dem
ah ouais c'est intéressant ça rich et
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
le les peines qui ont été qui ont été
rendues euh sont assorti d'un surcil
probatoire et là le surcis probatoire ça
veut dire que ils ont des conditions
pour ne pas aller en prison pour ne pas
faire les les 1 an en prison ils doivent
remplir un certain nombre de cases
d'abord ils ne doivent pas se revoir
ensemble ils doivent pas se concerter
ils doivent perdre tout contact ensemble
ils ne peuvent pas aller dans la ville
où vit précisément l'animateur donc la
victime ils n'ont pas le droit d'être
ils ont obligé ils ont une obligation
d'indemnisation de la victime ils ont
droit de regarder la
starac pas
ensemble et ils ont une obligation d'une
formation ou de travailler voilà les
quatre conditions donc ça c'est un
surpis probatoire assez assez bien fait
parce que s'ils ne remplissent pas ces
quatre conditions ils ne justifient pas
lors de leur contrôle du respect de ces
quatre conditions ils peuvent aller en
prison on leur enlève le Brasset
électronique et ils vont en prison
qu'est-ce- que vous voulez non je
trouvais que ce qui paraissait
inquiétant dans ce que vous dites c'est
que les magistrats ont tenu compte de
des excuses qu'ils avaient en disant non
excuses non parce que c'est ce que je
vous dis c'est quand même pour une
tentative où il a il n a il n'y a eu
aucun en réalité il y a un préjudice
moral ou un préjudice d'anxiété il y a
même pas une détérioration de la maison
ils ont quand même é Copé entre 3 ans et
2 ans de prison donc c'est c'est sérieux
quand même ENF bon quand ah bon merci
euh merci beaucoup maîre vous embrassez
Nicos mais oui et vous pouvez l'appeler
pour l'embrasser aussi et je vous dis on
l'embrasse et samedi soir la soirée est
simple
ce sera il y a Anouna donc c'est ma
personne face Ana nouvelle émission
samedi samedi face et j'ai fait exprès
de m'arrêter juste avant le début de la
finale de la
starac